hello and welcome to a brand new series
of the pledge this week saw the arrival
of a new resident in Downing Street
Dillon the Jack Russell crossed rescue
dog the pint-sized wet-nosed little
bundle of energy has already proved far
more popular than the existing residents
not to mention the better hair if only
we'd known earlier that dogs are a
failsafe way to get attention and
distract from bad news welcome to the
home of poor some debates well he can't
be more barking mad and the rest of this
lot coming up I'm arguing election won't
solve anything
Nick says it's time for Tasers Rachel
thinks learning about slavery could help
tackle racism enough work says there's
nothing suave about Sauvage but first
it's Carole okay I want to talk about
Boris not the one hysterical remainders
have compared to Hitler and slated as a
dictator an anti Democrat and a quotes
over-promoted robber bath toy that was
Hugh Grant's deranged contribution but
Forrest the brave the strong leader the
true Democrat who's prepared to parole
Parliament and risk his party and his
Premiership to deliver what the people
of this country demanded and were
promised three years ago this week he's
been fighting a titanic battle with Tory
rebels determined to stop brexit at any
cost that's why he had to propound and
sack those who betrayed the government
he's right to tell em pays what they
want it doesn't matter it's what the
British people voted for that matters
now he wants an election because it's
clear Parliament is no longer fit for
purpose in just two days it's wrecked
his ability to get a deal out of the EU
and its proposed bill will surrender
power to Europe
what sort of p.m. does nothing in the
face of that Boris is right to fight
those rebels to the death because it's
history his resolve that will hand
Parliament's power to the people of this
country forever
[Music]
hello yes
panel it's been a new term after a long
summer break so Deal or No Deal
we think we all need a reminder of the
key phrases in the brexit debate Rachel
let's start with you what's in your box
[Music]
in place to trade with the EU and other
countries let's avoid those Reds
[Music]
stopping all unfinished oceans and bills
from progressing until Parliament
returns it could be used to stop in
peace holding up brexit Majid let's see
what you've got
ah the gourd squad the group of
conservative MPs including former
Justice sacred a big bull who want to
stop a No Deal Brett said no matter what
Boris Johnson says Carole the last one
to you favorite of many a backstop way
of avoiding a hard border with physical
barriers or checks between Ireland and
Northern Ireland it was part of the
agreement made between Theresa May and
the EU now team an extra bonus point if
any of you can work out the numbers five
two four eight anybody remember June
three years ago 52 plays 48 well done
team
town boxes down and Rachel I understand
that brexit has made us all think a bit
oddly and perhaps that combined with the
summer heat has made us miss what Boris
Johnson has done he has shut down
Parliament no yes he has he and his
ministers have suggested they might be
above the law and he has just sacked 21
moderate long-standing Conservative MPs
now if Jeremy Corbyn from the Labour
Party were to do any of those things
we'd all be up in arms
days we'd be accusing him of this
vicious Stalinist purge I don't know why
you think Boris Johnson should get away
with this I mean presumably presumably
you cherish the parliamentary democracy
that we have in this country and I've
reported from many countries where
people would fight tooth and nail to
secure that kind of democracy so I don't
understand why you would be so gleeful
to want to trash it just to get it
correct in one thing a judge of Scotland
has ruled today that it was not unlawful
so he didn't break the law and Perot
compartment you know as well as I do and
everywhere around the table knows
Parliament is probed regularly John John
I'm sorry one of your leaders Clement
Attlee didn't focus then but more
recently John Major did both in 1992 and
1997 and he wasn't caught it and he did
it to stop a very damaging report about
cash for questions coming to life so
let's not pretend that this is unusual
this is this is used as a means to bring
long Parliament's to win it and we're
talking about six parliamentary days
there would have been plenty of time to
debate when partner comes back in
October Carol you can't be happy though
and I'm support quite a lot what you say
about Boris Johnson I do think if
anyone's going to get there it's in but
you cannot support the position that
conservative party finds itself in now
and that someone such as the grandson of
Winston Churchill there's no room for
him there's no room for I think at least
two former Chancellor of the Exchequer
one of whom was imposed only a matter of
weeks ago and they're all booted out
Rachel's on to something they have with
the way Boris's behave that's too much
Boris has always been clear that we
leave on October the 31st with a deal or
without a deal if any vote strips him of
the ability to do that that I think he's
justified it that is in effect a vote of
no-confidence and if those n pays were
allowed to come back in any new
Parliament after election exactly what
is happening now would happen again we'd
have another three years of this
nonsense people the conscripts not
conservatives they were told they would
lose them if they voted with Corbyn on
this we can't go on for years in years
in this state of limbo the British
people voted for something and they're
sick of what's happening and what's
happening
is not democracy what's happening is
deranged and insane the way the
remainders are babe because the stripped
Prime Minister they've stripped our
prime minister of the ability to
negotiate with Brussels and get us a
deal they stopped it's really important
but I think in times such as these that
all of us try to use language that
doesn't further inflame justice just as
we're not traitors you're not racists
right I think it's really important that
we all try and use language that in
times like this brings unity and that
begins I think by acknowledging what
Rachel said I'm a fierce critic of
Corbin but I agree if Corbin had had
overnight sacked or removed the whip
from 21 of his MPs it would have been
called upon to do this Johnson did him
discussing right ate of Boris Johnson's
cabinet members also voted against their
government under treasom a when she was
Prime Minister it's not as if this is
something new and they weren't sacked
the reason they're in his cabinet right
now is because of the which it was a
huge success
but what I'm saying is actually it's
there's a whiff of hypocrisy here and
removing the wick from people for what
you've done yourself the other thing I'd
say is actually Horace Johnson's correct
in saying that Peruvian Parliament
wasn't unconstitutional is the judge has
ruled in his favor
unconstitutional but it was highly on it
was highly unconventional and just as
conventions aren't binding so you can't
they don't have legal force and it's not
illegal to break them if that's the
argument we're now using then the
referendum itself wasn't legally I think
you know my question I mean I think
there's more than a whiff of hypocrisy
about this carol i thought it was
fascinating to hear Nicola Soames
grandson of Winston Churchill in the
Commons saying how he had been removed
from the party he served for 37 years
because of the kind of disloyal teeth
which Boris Johnson has been such an
inspirational source you know it's
impossible to take this man as someone
of integrity the very things that he's
penalizing people for exactly what he
has been doing and it's so ironic that
brexit
always been presented as a way of
preserving the sovereignty of this
country when if if you have any
understanding of our Constitution
parliamentary sovereignty is at the
heart of it the idea of trying to shut
down Parliament if I can't take I don't
know if you even believe it when you say
that this the timing is coincidental
nothing to do we tried to stop speedy
carlo and sovereignty has given to me by
the people of this countries they don't
just have it it's given by the people
the people are sovereign to undermine
the sovereignty of parliament there is
also no mandate to trash our
constitution our constitutions are
subtle it's a subtle instrument it's not
the relies on convention it also relies
on respect conventions and mock recei
and rule of law which which the remain
us have broken time and time again here
at governments it's actually terrifying
and I just like to show you also there's
that and then there's also just the
conduct and the tone yes and here I give
you leader of the House Jacob Riis MOG
who I think if a picture speaks a
thousand words this is the most powerful
image our house of parliament the
foundational institution about democracy
[Laughter]
you think is ridiculous the people of
this country are happy about what Boris
is doing the latest YouGov poll after
keep her own moment let's look at the
figures right so a month ago 38% thought
he was decisive now 62% that's gone of
24
he's honest so why are you looking at
that figure and you're constantly the
people like the decisiveness because
under Boris Johnson the Conservative
Party is in danger of becoming nothing
but the brexit party it's a small
minority faction that a project and they
have a point two percent mandate this is
what Dominic grieve the former attorney
Attorney General of that very party has
said what has happened is unfortunately
section of my party has become hijacked
by a narrow sector of those who voted to
leave and who are simply using the will
of the people as an instrument of
potential tyranny towards any of those
and I suspect that the Prime Minister
knows full well that soft brexit oh
sorry those are backed Tories amaze deal
and voted for it more times than he did
and remain errs are all United and
opposing that faction who supports
Rachel do you agree with me that the
only way to resolve this now as a
general election
I do actually agree that the only way to
resolve it is a general election I do no
no absolutely
listen absolutely there should be a
guarantee that that legislation to stop
No Deal has gone through Parliament
before any talk of a general election is
called that is absolutely the sensible
thing to do and I think I think I think
the Labour leadership should be credited
for putting national interests above
their own interests in what they're just
ongoing